all right this one is for parents
watching intermountain healthcare the
sponsors of this segment is here to
remind you how important it is to
protect your child's head in cars and
while outdoors so thank you for joining
us dr bragg you tell us about your
position because you're not just a
pediatric neurologist
actually i'm a pediatric neurosurgeon
okay yes i'm the only board certified
full-time pediatric nurse surgeon in the
entire state of nevada wow
so i started here in march of 2020 and
we've been really
grateful to help the community
in pediatric neurosurgery so let's talk
about the numbers here when it comes to
you know protecting your child's head
what are you seeing out there
so um in terms of like car accidents you
know there's been a huge jump from 2009
about a 40 increase of fatalities in the
state
and in terms of concussions we see a lot
about about 4 million not locally of
course but in the in the country what i
tend to see
can range from anything from children
falling off beds
jumping
off of trampolines and so we see a lot
of ina accidental injuries right but we
also see some high-speed motor vehicle
accidents children ejected from vehicles
if they're not properly restrained wow
well thank you so much for what you do
that's it's hard to talk about um just
imagining these children going through
this so let's talk about the head
protection um checklist i guess you
could say first seat belts how important
is that so obviously seat belts are
really critical
at all ages and most parents are aware
of you needing proper seating for
infants
but once kids reach about 40 pounds and
40 to 60 pounds they're actually
appropriate for boost receipts okay i
think that's probably the area that's
most missed in terms of safety just
because we tend to think of an
eight-year-old maybe old enough to wear
a seatbelt and they're really not yeah
and so the
purpose of the booster seat is to really
protect um
mostly abdominal trauma but obviously
the seatbelt is important to protect
head injury as well absolutely the
entire you know the whole body right
there and then of course you're
mentioning safety seats um there's
the don'ts of safety seats one one point
is destroy a child safety seat if it has
been involved in a crash let's talk
about some of those points yeah so um
safety seats are rated most of the time
they expire within six years so
obviously passing them down from child
to child is okay for a short period of
time right and then in any time
just like we would for a football helmet
anytime you've had a significant injury
or a bike helmet you need to replace
that safety seat so that your children
are protected and concussions and
helmets of course are also on the list
so obviously most of us think about
football helmets right and we think
about
appropriate padding for football or for
even for soccer
but i actually see quite a few kids
particularly after the holiday season i
saw a lot of kids having accidents with
hoverboards and so things that you're
really not thinking about even
skateboarding and it may not be the
coolest thing to do but you only got one
brain so it really would be appropriate
to wear a helmet and any other
protective gear to protect from long
bone fractures wrist fractures knee
knees and ankles okay well thank you so
much doctor back there's a great
reminder for parents out there we have
to protect ourselves and our children so
thank you again to intermountain
healthcare for sponsoring this segment
for more information just visit
intermountainhealthcare.org forward
slash nevada